oh you're ready for the night train oh
you're ready for the night train
are you ready for the night train he had
the voice
he had the moves chadwick trained for
two months
plus he stayed in character on and off
the 2014 set
up can you even imagine there was once a
time that you were
gonna pass on this movie i would have
been justified if i had passed on it
because
everything about the about the role is
hard
we've been dancing like five six days a
week gotta rest some days
uh and even going out dancing also it's
up
how do you practice a split in the club
well you don't practice that part
it was scary it's not going down it's
coming back up right
[Music]
[Applause]
i like him when he's a little bit more
fluent in his 30s
okay because you have all the rings and
the flash and the
clothes are amazing what y'all doing
what's your favorite piece
the afro it's so like beautiful and
classy i love
that era
that smile was electric my granny would
say he grinned from ear to ear and it
lit up
every single room that he was in